questa professionalità e oggi vado
mischiare tutti i miei slime questi non
sono suoi infatti da me ma sono stati
comprati o che mi sono stati inviati
quindi sono super curiosa di vedere come
diventeranno tutti mischiati andremo
anche a rivederne e alcuni di qui
completamente dimenticata
andiamo a vedere come sono diventati
sabato la super curiosa provate a
scrivere ora nei commenti secondo voi di
che colore uscirà il mega slime con il
mix di tutti gli estremi vediamo che
indovina proprio destino
ora però il video vedremo chi ha
illuminato in più alla fine del video
potrete mettermi minuti li i commenti
degli slam che vi sono piaciuti più di
tutti siete pronti mettetevi comodi il
video tutto schermo cuffie se volete o
non la so che un bel laicali siamo
subito abbiamo preparato il contenitore
scusate è un po celeste perché deve
trovare un altro slime non si toglieva
allora iniziamo subito con la posta
musica che se lo ricorda questa vediamo
un po come diventata trasparente con le
palline sì un pochino in un ritmo più o
meno è uguale perché resistita così
tanto e fa i suoi cronici vi ricordate
ancora sony crowns incredibile durata
benissimo prossima trasparente quelle
palline
anche questa è rimasta uguale
praticamente
sentite che ebbe il suo di fmr via
mettiamo anche questa
questa rosa che bel colore verde acqua
che per i nero rosa prossima del dia una
dritta ma si spezzano un po perché vanno
scaldati un po con le mani sto iniziando
essersi un arcobaleno di colori o
passiva abbiamo un'altra trans con le
palline blu
la maledizione del verde
ecco un altro bardolino scuro che bel
colore sono sorta di fucsia con tutte le
stelline
il rosso è bello mi dicono che questa mi
sa che era il mio preferito terra e
trasparente con le farfalline frase che
bello
evelyn schingo
come causa
va bene
e questo è l'ultimo delle pasta ma gk st
squizzi
devo dire che si sono ottenuti tutti
benissimo incredibile quindi questo è il
primo strato di slime cioè che figata
se tutto un arcobaleno nuovo bellissimo
e ora passiamo degli altri slime
frassini slime i monster portion blue
bay
[Musica]
guardate un po come finora il nostro
super miscuglio di slime questo sopra
più cicli infatti posso anche tirarlo
scusate il mio vicino ha deciso di fare
casino proprio adesso
ora passiamo ai prossimi slime tristi
frozen della big ten un bouquet morbidi
anche queste si sono conservati
bellissimo lo spoore morbidi
parte bene questo ma ho scritte wow
teheran una cosa per cosa per separarla
anche per questo fronte daniele
nello score
poco all'ultimo dei tweet brillantini ok
[Musica]
io ero passiamo al jardine scotto un
puffo o cotto un passo vediamo un po
a disp j wow
ok ragazzi allora li abbiamo mischiati
tutti ce li abbiamo messi tutti nella
vaschetta e ora andiamo a mischiare
guardate un po quanti colori ancora
tante qua sotto
che bello tantissimi colori guardate sta
staccando come lo stop piegando vediamo
un pò di che colore diventa super
curiosa iniziamo a mischiare capello e
marcello di qua dentro è tutto store
morbido
quanti colori
ancora più con i battenti rinnegare il
boves
ad aver milioni di colori
ecco qua come è diventato penso che
forse quasi nessuno abbia indovinato il
colore perché è un colore arcobaleno una
sorta di mix io non mischiato termico di
tempo per cercare di fa di avere un
colore uniforme insomma però siccome le
consistenze degli slide sono quasi tutte
diverse
non si riesce a mischiare completamente
inter un colore uniforme ma a me piace
tantissimo questo effetto colore super
arcobaleno
guardate un po quante sfumature a un
bellissimo e so che sono fantastici
quindi che scritto slime arcobaleno o
galaxy o mix di colori comunque ha
indovinato quanto che su blu forse è un
po più blu e marroncino quindi versione
del vizio di questi slime la sate bellei
che se volete vedere altri video smr
altri video slime ben roghi lasciato a 4
castellini su cui cliccare per vederli
miei altri di biblica più su quella che
per kate buone ammissioni ciao